like I was violent but I didn't know is
this messed up my thoughts when people
say pro wrestling is it's not
professional why does anyone watch
wrestling's I think fake is she giving
birth to a pro wrestlers it's how it all
began there's the start of the soap
opera how does this relate to what's
going on in the ring that it's a it's a
hand a hand was in her vagina
masturbating that looks like one of the
people from Golden Girls
I like this on sometimes are we fake
blood okay so like that is absolutely
insane it just shows you that this some
of this must be real right if you throw
someone off like a 15 meter thing like
that hurts these are all crimes that's
that's backflip that's not honestly that
wasn't a pretty amazing flip though I
have to say oh that was a good mission
that was impressive why is he in a
funeral home don't do something weird to
the body die god this is like very
pretty little eyes right now we just
said you look better dead is that a boob
grab we've got a corpse food grab that's
like a really bad example to set for
young people don't roses kids watching
this [ __ ] he's getting naked that's
[ __ ]
this is cool this is nice no this is
just that's beautiful
I didn't come here for this I didn't
come here for this
he caught me I'm a - I think that
wrestling obviously has the ability to
give people a lot of hope when it comes
to like it's an escapism thing I think
that my views on wrestling have changed
I've been confirmed that it's a soap
opera with like a little bit more
violence a lot of people aren't just
watching it for the sex with dead bodies
and the gratuitous violence but it's
also it's about entertainment for
everyone and they get to have just a bit
of fun with it still think it's still
after watching that I think it's in
massive aspects of wrestling that are
very problematic and something that I
probably wouldn't want to expose my own
children or even myself - whatever works
here you just don't go around doing them
in real life